well it's been two days uh since we last
recorded and uh so better yeah yeah so
in those within those last few days uh
Sydney's family have come to visit
um is it the first time in Japan it is
their first they're very American right
in Japan and it has been an eye-opening
experience to say the least okay because
I didn't know if I'd had enough to talk
about within just because I've they've
only really been here for one day right
so I spent yesterday taking care of them
yeah
um and it was certainly eye-opening to
see their perspective on okay
where are the cheese Cuts yeah so to
give a bit of perspective you know
Sydney's family is uh very like when you
think of a Midwestern American family
they are the most typical Midwestern
American Family you can think of I think
the only time uh the only time they've
been outside of let's say they've been
to Asia was to visit Thailand
um and that was because they wanted to
visit my family and stuff like that sure
and I don't think they'd ever been even
like closely close to like acclimated or
even introduced to Asian culture or just
like the Asian mindset before Thailand
um so how seeing them here in Japan
which is probably like Asia hard mode
you know what I mean it's it's no it's
well it's unlike a lot of other Asian
countries in a lot of ways yeah yeah
exactly even for Asian countries
um you know Thailand is a bit more I
would say
friendly or like used to having like
foreigners come in and tourists comes in
as well
um it is Japan is even more on the side
of okay we operate our own way and uh
people are just gonna have to get used
to that you know that's totally fine
um but you can have a much bigger
culture shock than you can in other
Asian countries
so yeah so
it's it's uh it was eye-opening for me
because I think in our generation we
have been like introduced to a lot of
different like
a lot of different cultures in the world
you know just by being on the internet
you know yeah and just by
just by being on the internet we see how
different cultures operate and stuff
like that obviously for people in the
older generation that have never really
gone out of like European or American
culture it's something yeah yeah your
parents right
um it's it was it was certainly weird
seeing them seeing how they like
so the first thing that really blew
their minds and I had to like explain
this to them like over and over again
you do not tip here
there's certainly multiple other like
explanations it's probably just so
ingrained into their system right where
it's just like they just accidentally
leave some cash on the table Yeah
because every time you every time they'd
uh encounter someone in the service
industry here they'd ask why are they
doing this not for tips
doing his job not for teams but yeah
because the the first encounter they had
was uh going to the hotel and having a
guy
um bring their bags up and there and I
told them before I've seen it on before
though you don't need to tip anyone here
and they had assumed okay that means
they don't have to tip the waiters here
but you know they
could mean you have to tip you know your
handlers here they're you know taxi
drivers that's a whole different deal
yeah yeah yeah
um so it's just their first culture
shock was just coming to like a service
industry hotel and just realizing that
people will just do things for them in
service of them to make them comfortable
uh without any incentive to like have to
tip or anything like that God forbid um
and I was like I was explaining to them
especially in bars and stuff because I
think bars was this was uh bars was
something we'll get to like bars in a
second but bars are something that's uh
in America you know I think
people like people in bars try to
cultivate a nice welcoming kind of
atmosphere so that they can get like
good tips and stuff yeah of course
tipping I think in like even above like
restaurants tipping in bars I think is a
massive thing because I think that's
where the biggest variance is
um and they were very surprised at just
how many small independent bars there
are in such like a densely compacted
area right and I'm like and they were
like how do they stay in business if not
for tips I like they they it like didn't
make sense for them that's the question
of the centuries I mean I I I've lived
here for like ages and I'm like I'm
still impressed we still don't know I'm
still impressed and I was saying instead
of working instead of working for tips
uh in a lot of places in this a lot of
these independent places in Japan
um I think it's more of like they try to
cultivate like uh uh what's what's like
a loyalty like a loyalty system right
like a patron system where you have
certain regular customers they come back
as often as possible I mean you can buy
a lot of balls and like smaller
independent ones uh you can buy a bottle
and they put your name on it so whenever
you come back in you can drink from that
bottle yeah because it'll pour you you
know and you'll see it because they'll
have like rows and rows of bottles
numbered or have name tags on them
um so that's that's like another way
that they try to make sure that you know
you come back a lot yeah yeah
um and so the first the first restaurant
I took them to yesterday was uh was a
sushi restaurant okay uh because I was
thinking Sushi's like entry level in my
mind well that's like the Japanese food
it's it's real thing about it yeah it's
the Japanese food and it's readily
available in America
um but you know even if it's readily
available in America take a Midwest you
know introduce a Midwestern family to
Sushi they don't eat sushi very very
often
um and uh cream cheese yeah yeah avocado
I mean it's full of California roll
where is it it made me realize that I
take it for granted just how like
acclimated a lot of our friends are uh
because the first challenge that uh we
came across was a Chopsticks Chopsticks
and I'd forgotten that Chopsticks were
just a thing that it's a skill that's
acquired it's a skill that's Acquired
and okay it did make me think a bit okay
it did it it did make me think a bit
after after seeing them have to like try
to navigate their way around Chopsticks
which in the end I was like just use
your hands because you know yeah you can
you can use guns with sushi here okay
they're like all right I guess I'll eat
the rice and the beef with my hands all
right yeah because one of Sydney's aunts
did ask for a fork I think and I was
just like just use your hands like it
just said
we are already standing out
I told my parents I was like hey uh
please practice Chopsticks a little bit
yeah
oh because okay it did make me think
okay because I've grown up with
chopsticks okay Asian household I've
grown upset it's a part of Asian culture
in a lot of Asian countries yeah
is it the best
children day
period to forks and spoons and knives
the more I use it the more I think there
are circumstances where it's good and
there are other times I'm like dude just
the knife and fork is in the go yeah yes
the you know the Sprint's never going to
be replaced the spoon is no literally
there's no no competitor yeah that's
what this is the spork is the superior
option
the spork okay here's the thing the
spork on paper is the superior is the
superior option to everything but can
you use it without feeling like a
five-year-old no no it does because it's
always plastic as well you know you
always kind of feel like yeah where are
the metal forms
middle Sports yeah yeah because because
I was thinking you know yeah I'm Asian
and I I always like promote you know
people trying to use chopsticks and
trying to like learn different cultures
and everything like that sure but I'm
like you know up I never needed a
tutorial to you like use a fork you know
and there was there was never
the thing Arc in my life to learn how to
use a fork but do you remember like the
first time you learned how to use a
chopstick no I was just I was kind of
born with one of my hands honestly like
a time I like
like I think I used Chopsticks until I
was like 15 or 16. yeah right and I
remember having a hard time like I
remember it was tough and like I
remember I would get like hand pains and
wrist pains yeah because it would cramp
right I was holding it so hard yeah so
like tense yeah and it would cramp and I
I just remember it is tough like it does
take a little while it's not like plug
and play Like a Knife before no it's not
I used to use like the the in Japan they
sell like the the Hashi for children
yeah where like the ends are connected
and it's like kind of on an axis yeah
you should use actually I think was it
we use that foraki's Mom I saw some
YouTuber that would they went around
Japan and they would always bring it
with them yeah oh yeah so they were
ready to go I mean it helps honestly
yeah because like I I remember because
like I remember
learning how to use chopsticks and I
think to this day there is like a proper
like Chopstick technique right it's kind
of kind of like hold it like a pen and
you use one of your fingers to like
adjust it you know I don't use that
technique I kind of like brute force my
way to just like figure out a way to
like open and close the Chopsticks like
it's it's kind of like an extent can we
actually yeah we have some Chopsticks
let's let's let's let's rate our
Chopstick techniques yeah and because
because it did make me realize huh you
know what because why do we have to go
through a learning Arc just to use one a
basic tool to eat or you just you
figured it out I figured out myself yeah
I've somehow figured out the way that
everyone else does it right I'm like you
know you know I'm like you know maybe
the Europeans were kind of onto
something because they they just they
just figured out a plug and play kind of
system
like I I guess with sushi a knife and
fork is not as good as a drink no no the
chops is tough because you're supposed
to own Sushi if I'm not mistaken okay so
Joey you have you have the proper
technique right show us the proper Tech
need to use the Chopsticks so the proper
technique I guess I kind of have to show
like this yeah yeah I do it right yeah
um but for me yeah this bottom Hershey
stays like let's stay still probably
just move the top one yeah but I have
seen people like my granddad for example
my channel yeah I'm not Chinese
my Japanese Granddad and my sister they
do like a cross technique they do this
oh I've seen that and I'm like and then
and then and then they pull it up and
they do this and I don't know how to do
that but my granddad did it my mom does
it my sister does it and I I do it this
way that's the correct way how do I do
it oh this is hard Chopsticks yeah so
when I eat I do like that yeah so that's
correct I don't know okay that's just
like the way I think that's correct okay
so that's that's the correct way and
that's like I I only use that if I I
only use this way because if I need like
Precision because with this one you can
really get precise yeah because some
restaurants right like yeah it's rude to
leave any rice Left Behind yeah unagi
right if you get nunagi and you leave
the rice it's like yeah well it wasn't
good enough but yeah you have to eat
literally every single grain of rice and
you [__] need that yeah because
you've got to go around the box like
picking every grain up yeah so this is
the correct technique to use as
Chopsticks I think is it not are you
holding it weird like how are you
holding it oh because I I was going to
say I was going to say I have my own
method of using Chopsticks that I guess
I guess I just developed as a kid yeah
because [__] is that right yeah yes
this is just my own technique which is
which is I don't know how you pick up
something okay so you pick up something
you just like bring it in and you use
one of your fingers to like part the
Chopsticks like that I okay and this is
the worst way it is the worst way but it
was like the only way that I could like
try to pick up the chip yeah okay this
bag because like it was it was the only
way like I could like do it it's just
impressive that they've worked my God
does that look inefficient it looks like
probably if no actually this uh this the
reason I use this technique is because
like my parents were just like that's
not the proper Chopstick technique use
the proper Chopsticks I think like like
this the Precision technique and I that
this would just give me hand cramps I
was like Mom this just ain't doing it
for me okay so I'm just like I just I
just tried to like find a way I just try
to find a way to like make my hands not
cramp and this way was just if it's like
it's more comfortable on my hands and I
could I can pick up like I can pick up
stuff I can do normal things but it's
not very good with precision and it's
awful with Korean style Chopsticks as
well I hate Curry I hate metal chops
yeah metal Chopsticks I hate it yeah
when you bite because like you know
sometimes you have some foods you're
trying to put it in your mouth from the
Chopsticks and you sometimes you
actually touch the Chopsticks right yeah
yeah almost like a barbarian but again
metal like oh question how do you hold a
pencil then I don't hold a pencil
because the way I hold the Chopstick is
the way I hold a pencil uh
uh yeah I like that yeah like this right
okay I hold it like this I guess I guess
how the [__] are you doing I don't know
this one this has always just felt
uncomfortable for me I I guess I I you
know I just realized I guess I hold the
pencil the same way I hold a chopstick
yeah but that's that's all it is right
you just you get the you just pretend
the pencil is the top Chopstick and then
you just slip the bottom one underneath
and you hold on to it you guys don't
want to know how god holds his dick when
he pisses us
a picture of like yeah
yeah exactly how I do it yeah yeah yeah
like that yeah so I have my own like
home brew method of like holding a
chopstick and using a chopstick and it
works it works my entire life if it
works it's just like some foods even in
Japan where I'm like man this is just so
much harder with the chop like
Chopsticks right like let's say you want
to uh
um
so even even like sushi sometimes
Sushi's supposed to dip the meat in the
soy sauce yeah so that means you have to
grab it and then kind of turn it yeah
yeah which is kind of a hard time even I
struggle to do that because sometimes
the sushi will fall the um the rice will
separate from the fish when you turn it
upside down I'm like dude okay one hands
Superior for the sushi I mean with sushi
I just I just use my hands yeah that's
fine but like um sometimes if you're
having uh something that you need to dip
into like three things yeah let's say
you're having like a beef bowl or like a
shogayaki or something yeah or you're
getting rice and then you're grabbing a
piece of meat and then you want to dip
it in mayo or some sauce okay I am like
getting four layers of things now and
I'm hoping it stays together yeah
whereas a fork you can just scoop stab
and then dip yeah like I can use
chopsticks to eat rice but I'm like
is is Chopsticks Superior to a spoon
like Superior to a spoon in in terms
like eating rice in terms of just like
ease of ease of use and uh functionality
you know because the thing is Chopsticks
look cool I'm I'm not gonna lie
Chopsticks just look cool and they feel
cool I can say this because I'm I'm
Asian
I'm bringing this up because I because I
like if Conor brought this up they would
be like like eyebrows like raising but
I'm like you know there's a kind of
Elegance to it yeah like it does feel a
bit more elegant I don't know why maybe
because it's like very precise yeah
um but there are some foods they've
given me Chopsticks in Japan where I'm
like no this is not allowed uh I went to
an Italian restaurant one time and they
serve me pasta with chopsticks oh that
yeah and I was like the [__] is this I
also refused
Italians are crying yeah I also refused
to eat salad with chopsticks as well
yeah maybe he loves eating salad like
some
yeah yeah I want to just stab all the
leaves and get them all I don't really
pick up each individual like leaf with
chopsticks yeah okay real sidetracked
anyway sorry yeah I I just realized that
uh you know trash day try not to have a
tangent challenge
fail because I just realized that spoons
and Fork don't really have a skill
ceiling and Chopsticks do and I'm like
an entry a barrier of Entry barrier of
entry and a skill ceiling as well
because you want to see my trick shots
with a spoon